[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTHONY GOLDBLOOM: Hi, everyone.
I'm Anthony Goldbloom.
I'm the CEO of Kaggle.
And as of-- actually, it was
at this event two years ago
that we announced that
Kaggle was joining Google.
So Google Next has a sort
of nice sentimental--
you know, it's
sentimental for us.
Just a quick show of
hands, how many of you
have heard of Kaggle before?
Well, I guess that's
why you're here.
How many of you have
a Kaggle account?
Oh, nice, this is good.
How many of you have either
submitted to a competition,
written a kernel, or
downloaded a data set?
Cool.
So hopefully, the percentage
got a little bit low
towards the end.
But hopefully,
this is so exciting
that by the end of
this talk you're
all dying to do all
three of those things.
So we run as our own brand and
our own team within Google.
You can think of us as--
we're a very large
machine learning
community we have 2.8 members.
And actually, we
were 840,000 when
we joined Google two years ago.
And so our growth is sort of
a reflection of how machine
learning has grown and evolved.
And so one of the things we
think a lot about is how do we
give our community-- we're a
platform neutral community,
and so people can use
whatever they like.
But Google has a lot-- one
of the really nice things
about partnering
with Google is Google
is, my opinion, the world's
best data analytics,
machine learning company.
And Google Cloud
is really moving
towards being the best cloud
for data analytics and machine
learning.
And so one of the
things that we've
been starting to experiment
with a little bit
is what are the ways that we
can give the capital community
exposure to Google and
Google Cloud tools?
And so we're just at the
beginnings of this journey.
A lot of our first
couple of years at Google
have been focused on aligning
with Google infrastructure,
security and privacy policies.
As a small start up, you
have a different stance
on things like GDPR to
a company like Google.
And now that a lot of
that work is behind us,
we're thinking a lot about
what are the ways, what
are the things that
Google has that would be
very exciting to our community.
And so Rachael is
going to give you
a bit of a sense for some of the
early things that we have done.
And then, as Rachael
said, there's a Dory.
So we're very happy
to take questions
about what are the kinds of
things we're thinking about
and what sort of
things might be coming.
So I'm going to hand
it over to Rachael.
RACHAEL TATMAN: Thank you.
And if you haven't used
any of the Dorys before,
it should be in the
app under this session.
There's a little Q&A button.
And if you hit that, you
can answer questions.
And we'll try to save a nice
big chunk of time at the end.
Because I know
Kagglers are the best,
and you guys always
have lots of questions.
And I want to make sure we
have time to address those.
So I think most of
you know what Kaggle
is, based on the show of hands.
The thing that I
first and foremost
think about when I think
about Kaggle is the community.
It's really a technical
professional community,
where people who are
entering the space
or have been working for a while
can make friends, hang out,
hone their skills, learn
things, share resources.
And eventually, we want
to be able to support you
in doing all of your data
science work on Kaggle.
What's on Kaggle?
People, lots of people--
I know I mention
the community a lot.
But I think Kagglers
are the best.
We've got over 2.7 million
users at this point.
I think we have around 300,000
people who log in every month
to write kernels, or
download data sets,
or enter competitions.
We also have 15,000
public data sets.
So these are data sets
that we've uploaded,
or mostly that
users have uploaded
that they want to share.
So things they've collected,
research data sets,
and we'll talk a little bit
about some examples of those.
And we also have a really large
body of scripts and notebooks.
So this is code for
doing different tasks.
And you can, of
course, work privately,
keep your data private,
keep your code private.
But people really are very
generous with their work
and share it and walk
people through how to do
various machine learning tasks.
So if you're trying to do
something kind of common,
let's say sentiment analysis
or object detection,
probably somebody has
already written a kernel.
And you can go,
give a little upvote
to-- you want to make sure
you upvote useful kernels.
And then fork.
And you don't have to
start from scratch.
You can use this pipeline
that somebody else has already
built. And it's a
huge time saver.
I am always using other
people's Kaggle kernels
to get my work started.
So we're probably best known
as a competitions platform.
That's sort of how
we got our start.
And we absolutely still do that.
But these days, Kaggle is a
lot more than competitions.
And I want to highlight
some of the things
that we've done recently,
some of the changes.
So the Kaggle products that
I personally probably use
the most is kernels.
What are kernels?
I mean, they're, like,
18 different things
in data science and
computer science.
So Kaggle kernels are a hosted,
in browser, coding environment.
So we support Jupyter Notebooks.
That's by far the most popular.
We support the Python
3 and R kernels.
We do not support Python 2.
And we also have scripts.
So these are flat files.
And we support Python
R, and also R Markdown.
So if you're-- any R
Markdown fans out here?
Yeah!
I'm a big fan of Markdown.
So you can write and
run Markdown on Kaggle,
and then you have a nice link
that you can share with people.
Or, I mean, of course,
download, and use blog down,
or book down, or slide down,
or whatever else you're
using in the ecosystem.
And we also have, once you
created your kernels, a really
nice way to share it.
You make it public.
You can post about
it on the forums.
If you haven't been on
the site in a while,
we now have a
personalized news feed.
So we've sort of algorithmically
picked some kernels
that we think might
be exciting for you,
or competition announcements
we think you might like.
So you can always see
what's new and happening
and people are talking about.
And there's a progression system
for kernels and data sets,
as well as for competitions.
So uploading other people's
data sets and kernels--
sorry, uploading other people's
forum posts and kernels helps
them progress in the
competition system, and say,
hey, this community
values my work.
That's just a nice
thing to learn about,
that others value your work
or to let people know that you
appreciate what they do.
So here is an example
kernel that is a little bit
small that I wrote.
And this is an R kernel.
I like R. I also use Python.
And this shows you how
to read in a wave file
and create a spectogram.
And if you're not
familiar, spectograms
are a time frequency, intensity
transformation of audio files.
It's a way to visualize
sounds, basically.
And this shows you the sounds
of ground parrots, which
are an Australian parrot
that lives on the ground.
And a bioacoustics
researcher just
uploaded a data set
of calls that they've
recorded from these parrots.
Now it's, like, I've got
an acoustics background.
I think that's kind
of interesting.
So I've just whipped up
a little visualization
to show what they looked like.
And if somebody else
wanted to do spectograms,
we do have a sound-based
competition going on right now.
You could copy this
kernel, fork this kernel,
read it in a different
data set, remove
the data set that
I'd used and just
reapply this code
to a new data set.
So I mentioned collaborations
and discussions.
Our forums are super
duper duper active.
It's a really great place
to ask technical questions
to a community of
other data scientists.
And of course, there's
lots of places to do that.
There's Stack Overflow.
There's Stack Exchange.
But particularly around machine
learning, deep learning,
machine learning engineering,
the Kaggle community
is really great and supportive.
And we also have events.
So some of those are in person,
and some of those are digital.
So an example of an in-person
event is Kaggle Days.
This is a picture
of everybody who
went to Kaggle Days Paris,
which was a little while ago.
We're currently actually
having Kaggle Days
right now in conjunction with
Next, which I'm afraid is full.
So if you didn't sign up ahead
of time, catch us next year.
And it's been really great.
We've gotten talks
by grand masters.
People have run workshops.
We're doing a little
on site competition
that people are working on
right now with manufacturing,
prediction, defect detection.
And it's been a
really fantastic way
to meet people face-to-face.
Because you spend so much time
chatting with them online.
Or maybe you've just seen
them going past in the forums,
and you're like,
oh, I don't know
if I could ever approach them.
And it's been really great
to meet people face-to-face.
So if you interested in coming
and hanging out with Kagglers,
keep an eye out for Kaggle Days.
And we also have online events.
And we know that we
have a lot of users
in different parts of the
world for whom it may not
be reasonable to get to,
say, Paris or San Francisco.
So we really want to make sure
that we're reaching everybody
and we're really
being accessible.
And even if you are in the US,
and you have small children
and can't travel,
we want to make sure
that you can still
grow professionally
as a data scientist.
So one of the things that we're
doing next week, actually--
you can still sign up for this--
is CareerCon.
And this is a
completely digital event
to help you land your
first data science job.
So I'm doing an educational
event as part of this
to help people who've
never made an API make
an API from scratch.
We're going to talk
about open API.
You may know it as Swagger.
We're going to build
a little [INAUDIBLE]..
We're going to serve it.
We're going to go
through the process.
So you can have
something to show
on your portfolio or your
resume, saying, hey, sure.
I'm a data scientist.
And I'm really good
at machine learning.
But also I know a
little bit about what
software engineers do.
And I can play well with
them and my new teammates.
And you should hire
me, and I'm great.
Data-- I was actually originally
hired to be on the data
sets team.
And we used to, like
the Kaggle team,
individually go and find
interesting data sets
under open licenses and
upload them to Kaggle.
We don't need to do that anymore
because our community has been
so, so, so fantastic about
sharing data, research
data, just people
who have questions
that they would like to get
in front of machine learning
researchers that they've
collected the data for.
And if you have data that
you would like to share,
I would encourage you to put it
on Kaggle, assuming that we can
support your specific needs.
For example, we cannot
support HIPAA compliance.
Please don't give
us HIPAA data--
yet.
So here are some
example data sets
that the team actually
automatically maintains.
And these are open
data sets that we
think might be useful
in your day-to-day work.
So some things-- there is one
in here that San Francisco
restaurant scores, like
their health scores.
So if you're trying to
decide where to go for dinner
and you want to do
a quick little data
analysis to make sure
you pick the right place,
that might be something
you can work on.
But we've also had some
really fantastic user
uploaded data sets.
So you guys might be
familiar with kmnist.
It was uploaded by a
couple of our users,
including [INAUDIBLE],, who's our
youngest grandmaster currently.
[INAUDIBLE] see you.
And it is a drag
and drop replacement
for mnist, which is a
digit recognition data set.
Those of you who are
not familiar with mnist?
Yes.
OK.
So it's a data set for
recognizing handwritten digits
like one through zero.
This is the same thing, but
for Japanese classical texts.
So this team put
together this data set.
They released it on Kaggle.
And they actually
presented a paper about it
at NurIPS, which is
what NIPS is called now.
I'm not saying putting data
sets on Kaggle will get you
NurIPS papers.
But it's a really good place to
find interesting research data
sets that specifically tailor
towards the machine learning
community, which is fantastic.
We also had,
relatively recently,
some farmer who wanted to
train a drone to spritz
what's it called--
not pesticide, but
like for plants.
Fertilizer?
No, the other one--
AUDIENCE: Herbicide?
RACHAEL TATMAN: --herbicide.
Thank you, herbicide, a
specific weed that he had.
So he'd gone to his
field and he took
a bunch of pictures of the
specific weed he wanted
to target and uploaded
them so that people
could try their hand at a really
fun practical application.
So there's lots to
discover in data sets.
I love just, like,
going through there
and seeing what
people have uploaded.
And finally, Kaggle is a great
place to challenge yourself.
Of course, we have competitions.
They are, as you might
imagine, competitive.
We've got many
going on right now.
We've got image, using text.
We've got a sound one
going on right now.
So whatever it is you're
interested in, as long as it's
supervised, we'll
probably have something
that might tickle your fancy.
We also have a lot of support
for people who are learning,
who are newer to the data
science space, who maybe just
aren't compelled to compete or
don't find that particularly
motivating.
I personally tend to be more
motivated by finding out
new things than
doing, like, you know,
oh, got to get that
last hundredths
of a digit of accuracy.
And that's just, you know,
my personal learning style.
So here is an
example competition.
I know I talked about
CareerCon a lot,
but I'm really
excited, you guys.
Here's a competition
that we're going
to be doing as part of
CareerCon on robot navigation.
So if you're interested in
sort of agent-based stuff,
this might be one for you
to take a little look at.
And we also have a growing
number of Learn courses.
And these are not going
to take you completely
through the math in
a very detailed way.
Our goal with Learn is to
get you started very quickly
with practical examples.
So these are short,
and they're condensed.
And we want you to be
able to go through them
in, say, an afternoon
and then be able to apply
what you've learned.
So this is one that's
relatively new on machine
learning explainability that
Dan Becker recently released.
So if that's something
that you're interested in,
sit down, spend a few hours,
work through some hands
on examples, and know more--
maybe.
Unless you're already
researching machine
learning acceptability, in
which case I don't know why
you'd take a course in it.
OK.
So that's what's
on the platform.
I also want to talk about some
of our Google integrations
that we've already added.
And something that I was doing
as I was putting together
this talk was
really sitting down
and thinking, how
will these be helpful?
What specific people
can I see really
benefiting from
these integrations?
Because we want to make
sure that we're doing things
that people can take with
them and enjoy and improve
their work with.
So three things that we've
added relatively recently--
one is an integration
with DataStudio.
Who has used DataStudio--
OK, a fair number of people.
We've also added in
integration with BigQuery.
And also Google Sheets,
which I'm actually
very excited about, and
I'll talk about why.
I know people like to dunk
on spreadsheet software.
But it's a great tool, you guys.
Spreadsheets are great.
All right-- DataStudio--
so we have a little gif here
that's apparently starting
in the middle for some reason.
Interesting.
So you can click on
any Kaggle data set
and launch, with just
a couple button clicks
once you've connected
your DataStudio
account, a DataStudio
dashboard based on that data.
If you're not familiar
with it, DataStudio
is a way to visually
analyze data.
It's really nice for creating
dashboards, in particular.
And one use case where I think
this is going to be a huge time
saver is for people
who are working
in educational settings.
So particularly if
you want your students
to really analyze a specific
data set, just as an example,
the Arizona Secretary
of State releases
their data set of
election data as they
finish cleaning them on Kaggle.
So if you're a
government professor
and you want your students
to spend some time looking
at election data--
how many of you have done
mapping, or like gif stuff
in Python or R?
Yeah.
Is it, like, fast and
easy and something
you can do in 10
minutes usually?
Maybe some of you can.
But me, I'm always, like, oh,
I've got to pick a projection.
Oh, no, there's no FIPS code.
I've got to go get the
FIPs code from somewhere.
Or oh, I've got a
hook up a mapping
API because I don't
have, like, OpenStreet
on whatever I'm doing.
So I think this could be a
really fast way, particularly
for mapping.
Especially if you
want your students
to be focusing on the
information in the map and not
the going through
of the mapping.
Also, I mentioned dashboards.
I love Jupyter.
There are some things
that Jupyter is
really great for dashboarding.
There are some things where
it's a little bit less good.
So something that-- actually,
if there's any front end
people in here who would like to
contribute to Jupyter, there's
an HTML widgets bug that I
don't think the core team
is going to get
to because they're
focusing on Jupyter lab.
It's been around for a while.
And every so often, different
plots will render as one pixel
by one pixel.
Has anyone run into this?
Anyway, when you're working with
interactive plotting libraries,
that can happen.
And if you run into that, again,
it's just in the Jupyter core
and there's nothing I personally
can do about it, because I'm
not a front end person.
If you are, consider making
open source contributions
on this particular
bug that bothers me.
But using Datalab instead is a
nice way to work around that.
And it's also nice for your
teammates who are maybe not so
comfortable working with code.
I know that a lot of us
work in teams with people
with a variety of
backgrounds and goals.
So this is a nice way to
reach out and work with them.
BigQuery-- who uses BigQuery?
Oh, yeah?
OK, a fair number of people.
Who uses any relational
database or SQL, in general--
yeah, OK, pretty much everybody.
So right now you can access
public BigQuery data sets
through Kaggle kernels.
And we've got some very
small code examples.
I don't know why I thought
these screens would be bigger.
I think I thought the
room would be smaller,
so everyone would be
a little bit closer.
So you can create a BigQuery
client and run queries--
wow, I should have
had a second copy--
and run queries from
directly in Kaggle Notebooks.
And then take that data and work
with it locally, save it out
as another data set.
So if you save any files
from a Jupyter Notebook, when
you commit that notebook,
it'll run it top to bottom.
And your files will be
saved in the output,
and you can create a
new data set from those.
So if you're running a
BigQuery, or maybe you
have a teammate who's
not as familiar with SQL,
but they want to use some
of the BigQuery public data,
you can run the queries.
Create a data set from them.
And then point them to the
data set, which is really nice.
And if you are
perhaps the person
who is, like, I don't like SQL,
or maybe it's been a minute
since you used it, we
also have a SQL course.
Again, very directed--
we're not going
to get into, like, the parse
trees of SQL and [INAUDIBLE]..
We're not doing any of that.
It's just basics
of query writing
and specifically, talking
a little bit about BigQuery
and how to use it on Kaggle.
So if you're a
little trepidatious
about getting started, we
can help you out with that
and walk you through it.
So just for those of
you who didn't know,
we have a Kaggle
developer survey
that we reach out to the machine
learning community in large
and sort of get
information back.
And SQL is consistently the
third most popular language
after Python and R. So if
you are not a SQL user,
and you're working the
machine learning space,
it's good to know.
Finally, Google Sheets--
I really like
spreadsheet software.
I think I mentioned it before.
I think it's a really nice tool
set that makes a lot of things
very accessible to people,
because you don't have
the cognitive overhead
of trying to remember
what data structures look like
because it's there visually.
So I know people [INAUDIBLE]
on spreadsheet software.
But I'm a big fan.
So to open data sets in a
Google Sheet, you can do that--
I don't know if
you guys can see--
it's under that little sort
of hamburger, three-dot menu
in the upper right-hand corner.
And you can open it
as a Google Sheet.
It takes just a second.
And then it'll pop open.
So two places where
I think that this
might be a sort of
a surprising use
is first for project management.
So if you've got--
I mentioned that you can create
a data set from the output
files you generate
in any kernel.
So let's say you're working
with some competition teammates,
you're sort of deciding what
your hyperparameter search
space is going to be.
You generate a file with
sort of all the parameters.
You create a data set from
it, launch it as a sheet,
and then you can use
that as your sort
of base of operations.
Color code who's doing what.
You can ping people.
So you can be, like, this
action item is for you.
And they'll get an email,
which is really nice.
So it can be a nice
project management tool.
Because I know that that's
something that a lot of people
struggle with and I see a lot of
discussion about on the forum.
So if you don't already
have one and you're
working with other
people, Sheets
might be a nice integration.
And a really hacky one--
I'm sorry, guys.
This is extremely hacky.
But I think would be useful.
So one of the ways that people
do text data augmentations
who have a small data set, how
can you create new data items
for images.
You can flip it and rotate it.
What does it mean
to flip a sentence?
It sort of stops
becoming language.
One way that people
do this is they'll
translate from English
into an unrelated language,
like Japanese or Russian,
and then back into English.
Because you'll get sort of,
like, slightly different
sentences that are kind of
semantically equivalent.
And I don't know if
you guys know this,
but there's actually a Google
translate option in Sheets now.
So one way to do this
would be to create a data
set of the text data you
want, open it in Sheets,
translate it using
Sheets, and then create
a new data set from your
translated sentences
for your data augmentation.
I did warn you it was hacky, but
potentially, very useful if you
need to do text augmentation.
So those are some
of the integrations
that we have worked on so far.
More to come--
TM, veil of secrecy.
But there's lots
of exciting things
that we're working on
that I think you'll really
like and find useful.
And we really want to
make Kaggle a great place
to do data science.
So I encourage you,
during the Q&A--
I haven't checked the Dory.
Hopefully, everyone's
asking questions.
So let us know your feedback.
If there's specific
things you want to see,
we would love to hear that.
We really want to make
Kaggle a great tool.
I do almost all of my data
science work in Kaggle
and personally would like it to
be better for selfish reasons.
I think it's already very good.
But I'd love to hear what else
we can do to help you guys.
All right.
And also, there is
feedback in the app.
So I'm going to wrap it up,
and we can take questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]